we'll put the truth to one side in order
to be kind to people but is it
is it is it kind essentially to be
telling lies to people
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster
i'm constantine kitchen and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today
is a teacher journalist and
self-described opinionated trans woman
david hayden welcome to trigonometry hi
nice to meet you both uh it's great to
meet you great to have you here thank
you so much for coming on
uh we'll get into all your problematic
opinions in a second
uh but just tell everybody a little bit
about who are you
how are you where you are what has been
the journey that leads you through life
to be sitting here talking to us
right well i'm a teacher i've been
teaching for 25 years
uh i live in birmingham i teach i teach
in the west midlands
uh i uh probably wouldn't be sitting
here though
if i hadn't transitioned uh 10 years ago
and what led you to transition uh
mental health uh a mental health crisis
really
uh i'd had i'd had issues with
my well issues with my gender i've
sometimes described it but don't try and
push me on what that actually means
but i knew i had psychological issues
with this from
when i was about three years old but
managed to uh
as many other people do you manage to
keep it in check get on with life
grow up you know get married have kids
you know get a job
uh but around 10 years ago i
just found it increasingly difficult to
carry on as i was
as a man working as a man living as a
man i felt i should have been a woman
uh i actually felt i actually believed
at the time i was some sort of woman
so i transitioned and you got into
suddenly came to people's attention uh
to to certainly to our attention uh when
you you wore a t-shirt uh and help me
get this right because this is all a bit
minefieldy uh you wore a t-shirt saying
trans women are men
i'm really glad you're the one asking
this question yeah as am i
i'm am i right so far you're right i'm
right so far and then there was some
you know it got in the news and and
there was a big thing and then there was
a disciplinary action and blah blah blah
blah
now what why would you as a trans woman
wear a t-shirt saying trans women and
men well it's a political statement i've
always
i've always wanted to say things what i
believe in
as i said when i transitioned i thought
there was some sort of woman
by two years ago when i wore that
t-shirt
i realized there was no more a woman
than you two are
uh but uh we're bombarded with this
message
that transforming our women get over it
and
there's that second part of the student
which i think is equally important as
the first
you know trans women and women get over
it the message is to the rest of society
you've got to get over it you've got a
problem whereas uh
my message was trans women are men which
is an
equally valid political statement but
get over it
is directed inwards towards us because i
think if we
get over that fact we can live much
happier lives and much more secure lives
and much more confident lives do you not
think that there's inherent
contradiction though because
if you are a man what possible reason
would we have to describe you as she and
use female pronouns when you're not in
the room
well it's what you see and what you were
and how you naturally would
describe me uh we use we use pronouns
for inanimate objects like ships can be
she
so i would go with sec with uh
pronouns describing sex but pronouns
when i describe somebody else the
pronouns i use
to help me describe that person uh to uh
to somebody else and uh so if you were
describing me
if if that makes a conversation between
you easier then use it
if you use he then use he the most the
important thing about a pronoun is it's
text it stands in the where the noun so
that you know exactly which
uh noun or which person you're talking
about the reason i bring it up debbie
and i want to get into this a little bit
because i think this is where
one of the biggest disagreements there
is on this issue and
it might feel like we're getting into
the weeds to people but it is important
you know we had jordan peterson on the
show a while ago uh and
we were talking about the fact that
identity
is a negotiation between the individual
and society
and so to me it seems like the concern
about ensuring that people use the
pronouns which match the gender that you
now have
is about say you know when if i was to
say he about a trans woman who wasn't
you
that would be me deliberately or
possibly deliberately but it would be me
rejecting their attempt
to to have the identity of a trans woman
now people would might people would
argue that right
so the the reason i ask you the question
is if you are a man
why would i embrace the identity
that you now have which is you're a
trans woman you know you you've made
uh you've taken steps to be to appear
female right you've done that yeah to to
and that's a reflection of how you feel
inside but it's also a reflection of how
you i i'm putting things
on you now and you reject them at will
but you want
society to see you a certain way as well
and me using a different pronoun is me
saying i don't see you that way
and that's why i think a lot of people
are uncomfortable do you see what
i see where you're coming from but it's
you know it's
to me the most important person who
thinks it's me
it's how i feel about myself the whole
process of transition was to help me
feel comfortable with my body
uh you know uh why should i care what
you think
this this this is this is the issue you
think one thing
uh that shouldn't bother me if i've got
if i'm confident in who i am and secure
in who i am
your thoughts don't uh don't don't
concern me that that's that sounds uh
uh that sounds i'm being negative
towards you now but uh
you're entitled to it it just seems that
uh
others seem to look to other people to
validate them
i want you to think this about me so i
feel good about myself
which is just it's a fool's game because
even if you say something i'm not
convinced if you actually believe it
and and we get into that point well you
know constance says this but
does he really mean it and and i want
you to be honest you know
and uh and use whichever pronoun you use
use whichever pronouns you like
it it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't
bother me in real life where people know
me
uh there's a mixture used some people
use female pronouns about me
others use male pronouns about me and it
really it really it really doesn't
matter
uh really no it doesn't matter at all uh
so
my children use male pronouns because
i'm their father
uh but we just we just go with it so
uh you know the the the phone they we
still have a landline
but and it still still takes call and it
still takes calls which are not uh
people trying to uh solid stuff or tell
us our internet's uh going to be that's
how i know you're from the north
yeah but people ring and uh
so so we've got uh we've got the kids
who have been uh
using male pronouns so repeat this and
either and that's fine
and then the phone will go and i'll say
and and one of my
kids will ring yeah i'll go get out for
you and uh
you know so it's just it just labels
these pronouns
so let's say you had a colleague or
someone you knew
who insisted on calling you by the
incorrect pronouns you wouldn't be upset
offended angry even if you said to them
look i prefer these pronouns
no well no no well i wouldn't i wouldn't
guard anywhere to say you must use this
pronoun
yeah when when i transitioned there were
two tests of uh
whether you'd made a successful
transition as it was called
the aim was was to uh was to address
your
you know you mental health issues like
what call them what you will
the aim was to transition and then pass
unnoticed in society
you know and be taken at first glance as
a member of the opposite sex
so when when you heard people referring
to you by pronouns
when people would say uh she you thought
oh i'm doing something right here.
this this that you know i i'm you know
something's going going right here the
other one used to be being directed to
the toilets which is another
thorny it become a foreign issue so if
you said you know where the toilets are
and if you were directed to the women's
you think ah you know and you do
you you would you would you would ask
them you just didn't know and that would
be the uh
that would be the way of testing these
you know testing you know
your uh the way you're projecting
yourself uh to society
we seem to have uh we seem to have
turned that completely on its head
where now rather than me doing something
and then and then having society respond
it's telling society what to do you know
you shall use these pronouns or
you'll be uh you know whatever you know
a horrible person because you were
hate trans people and you think well no
it's it's the wrong way around you know
we should be uh
we should be taking our part in society
rather than
demanding things of society like this
and debbie why do you think it is uh
look
this is an issue which affects a tiny
portion of society it's a tiny portion
of society
and that doesn't mean they don't deserve
support and all the rest of it
but why is it that it has become so
politicized and becomes such a
mainstream issue
it's bananas isn't it it really is uh
when i when i transitioned the aim was
to uh basically stay out the press and
uh and keep your job which bit it's a
bit ridiculous now because i'm
you know but uh you know it has become
it it ceased to become a clinical issue
it used it used to be a clinical issue
we had a
we had a mental health issue and this
was a treatment for it and that was that
uh well it's become a it's it's become a
civil rights issue almost
uh where it's you know it's become a big
debating
you know debating issue in society i do
i do i do worry that it's being driven
by uh
by uh you know other vested interests i
do worry that this
is uh this is a way of doing two things
which is uh
which is uh compromising women's
boundaries and women's rights
uh women you know women erect
barriers in the way of men for very good
reason you know we've
you know there's just you know there are
just too many cases where men have been
where men have abused women it just it
just keeps happening
so women have to put those barriers up
and men don't necessarily like it
because they're not necessarily in
control of the situation
uh and the other one is the surf
guarding of children
and you know the tr you know
trans trans people such as me i think
i'll be
you know i would not i don't know i
worry that we're being used
in a political uh campaign to uh
you know to compromise those barriers
that that women have put up used by whom
uh men basically well i i'm not doing it
i'm not
which meant like who is it that's doing
it
well it's it's it's a good question
uh it's been it's been it's
it's an affront to uh women's uh
boundaries
in that women in traditionally have been
able to put up boundaries to men
and so look these spaces are ours this
this is this these are these are our
these are our species
if we let you in it's on our terms they
did
they did and have done that transsexual
people
through those uh we've had other right
we've had other
uh rights for women uh all women
shortlists in politics uh
oh places on committees or so whereas
we're in a position now where
a man can self-declare as a trans woman
and
you know we've had a big debate over
self-id but in a lot of places in
society
you say you know a man declares
themselves to be a trans woman and a
trans woman they are
and suddenly expect a free pass into
those spaces
they expect uh to be uh put onto a
an all-women shortlist you know into
politics if you uh
they expect they expect all those rights
and
suddenly women are there looking at
thinking well what's what's the point of
uh
yeah what's the point of having a door
we can lock on men
if if they if anyone can cut their own
key that's what that's what it feels
like to me
it's it's an affront on that power
imbalance between which
women have had to defend themselves
against a power imbalance and this this
thing goes against those defenses which
they've set up
now i get that i just don't understand
who who's who's using people
trans people for that purpose you you
talk about that in a slightly sort of
i mean not conspiratorial way but you
know what i mean and i'm just trying to
understand because
um is it really the case that lots of
people are
pretending to be trans women to in order
to get on a short list or
to get into a bathroom or whatever is
that is that common
a lot it's what you said about
pretending to be a trans woman how do we
know the difference between someone
who's pretending to be a trans woman
what is a trans woman you tell me
well yeah this this this this is the
question which sometimes get asked
what is a trans woman and
you know do we have do we have some sort
of
uh some sort of inner being somewhere in
here something called a gender identity
which makes me a trans man i've got a
different gender identity to you
well there's no evidence for any of that
you know there's
uh whenever you uh you know whenever you
look at
people there's no evidence there's
anything different in my brain
to your brains uh this this whole
concept of gender identity which
have been sold is well it doesn't it
doesn't need to exist
and in my view if it doesn't need to
exist why has it been invented
and it's been invented to create this
concept of this trans person you are
trans because you have this
almost like a soul-like uh you know
concept inside inside yeah
you've got a female soul or something uh
that's that's that's what we get uh
that's what we get
told but if you take that away then say
you know what is you know what is a
trans woman
and one very pr you talked you know you
mentioned about being an opinionated
trans woman
you know one thing you know one
suggestion which i would never be
allowed to say on twitter
carefully if you tweet this is that
trans women are men
with a certain type of psychological
disorder
which creates an insatiable need to
present in the same way as a woman
but it doesn't mean that we're a woman
and why can't we say that
uh because it denies people's identity
and is it just as simple as that just
the fact that but you know
if somebody says there's something and
surely other people have the right to
critique it or deny it
even if they think that that's true yeah
and and the other thing is when when
people say well
we we've got a question on the census
you know do you have a gender identity
which is different to your
sex you know to your biological sex as
what as a sound at birth
uh or whatever whatever language the
government have decided to put on there
but this has reached the census do you
have a gender identity
and uh to say well this i don't think
this actually exists
is uh it's a big thing is that but who
who came up with the idea
you know one question i sometimes ask of
people who who said this is
who told you that and why did you
believe them because
it's gone round saying that everybody's
got a gender identity and you say well
who told you and but it's because
everybody seems to think it
that uh it must be true yes
as a scientist i always like to look for
evidence in this so
that's a really interesting thing so
your view and correct me again as i'm
wrong i'm just trying to understand this
as i go because
it's new to me yeah i've not heard many
people say
what you've just said uh who who are
themselves have had that
you know you get trolls on the internet
going uh
you know trans women and men they should
get back in whatever
in a sort of aggressive angry way but
i've never
what you're saying is
be being trans is a
psychological disorder is that
yeah i think the problem is it's the
loading on the word disorder
yeah this thing is bad whatever whereas
you know
what's what's wrong with having a
disorder it's an abnormality maybe
well this this is another word it's
these words are seen as pejoratives but
uh as a physics teacher uh one of my
jokes is we can all be normal
as long as we stand up straight so the
view we have is that
normal is he's 90 degrees to the surface
yeah
and uh and to be all you know to be
disordered just means
not ordered yeah and in its true sense
that means all standing in line
one two three four five well i prefer to
stand off to one side and be myself
so this idea to say that trans women are
men with a psychological disorder
is political dynamite yes yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah
uh shouldn't it be an art shouldn't it
be a claim
that we're allowed to argue in debate no
100
completely do you sometimes think with
this debate that in an effort to be
compassionate
we're sacrificing truth reason and logic
yes it's uh uh truth
is truth is truth and uh we're we're
we're hiding the truth we're obfuscating
the truth we're uh
and we're yeah we're avoiding the truth
we'll put the truth to one side in order
to be kind to people but is it kind
essentially to be telling lies to people
well this is where i come back to
to this idea of identity being a so
partly a social construct i i do think
that you're asking a lot of people to to
expect that they only care about how
they perceive themselves even for people
who who don't have that
let's call it disorder just for use of
like for ease of language
even for people who don't have that you
know very few people of that
independently minded that they simply
don't care how
anyone perceives them you know we all
put on clothes and makeup and
you know jewelry and whatever to make a
certain impression on others
it's just part of how we evolve right
we're social beings
so i i have to say i do get the argument
that
by you know not using the pronouns or
denying someone's way of thinking about
themselves
that has an impact don't you think yeah
i think it's i think it comes down to
the fact that our identity is
it is intermeshed with with our
relationship with society yeah exactly
and when i was
when i was uh coming here today you know
everybody i met was was uh i was
referred to as female female pronouns
i don't think for a moment my identity
was being uh
was being denied at all uh but i don't i
don't have a badge that says you must
use uh
female pronouns but the way i interact
with society means
people tend to use female pronouns
because they're more comfortable
referring to me by
female pronouns yeah and it's whether
it's
it's yes we have an eye we have id we
have personal identity i know who i am
but we also we're also social beings
living in society
and it's it interlinks with how you
see me but what what the problem i think
we're having is
uh it's other people and
and be careful who else who i talk about
here because
i i don't want to put the finger
individuals but it's it's the philosophy
that
i am going to uh you know i'm going to
demand
that society treats me in one way by my
words
but my actions how i live my life is a
different way and that's
that's the clash and i'm going to expect
society to uh
to cope with that whereas i i don't i
don't do it i live my life one way
and and it people tend to
take me as i want to be taken so
i guess what you're saying is you've
made your best effort
to present as a woman and people can
take it or leave it essentially but most
people will take it because you've made
therefore whereas
if you came in here with a beard and a
whatever
and looked just like a man you have less
reason to expect people to treat you as
a woman yeah
and and to use one example if i'm uh if
i'm walking home alert at night
and it's dark and i'm by myself uh
and i've got i've got my big coat on
then i'll turn me i'll
i'll tie my hair back i'll put my
quarter i'll put my hood up uh
make sure i'm wearing jeans and uh i put
my shoulders out and i'll get taken for
a man
it's much safer uh and
in that case then i wouldn't expect
people to use female you know if
you know if if it was being referred to
then i wouldn't
i wouldn't uh expect people to use
female pronouns in that situation
you've got the best of both worlds well
yeah i've sometimes said to people that
uh we we may put male privilege to one
side but we can we can take it back
whenever we want it
and in that that is that is one example
of that so i can
i you know the the male privilege which
i may try to put to one side
come straight back and i can walk down
the street at night and
because people yeah people imagine they
see
well you know people see a man so uh
i don't i don't i don't suffer the same
uh
issues that a woman would do walking
alone at night and
that leads us rather nicely into the
issue of non-binary that is something
that i still struggle to get my head
around i'm going to be honest with you i
still don't really get it
can you explain what non-binary actually
is
and your opinions on it well aren't we
all non-binary are you
binary am i buying that i'll be honest
with you
i never expected that people do keep
comparing them to sue perkins yeah
but it's it's a good what do what does
binary mean
uh i guess it means that somebody uh
identifies uh
completely with the uh uh you know with
the stereotypes and characteristics
which are expected of men or women in
society but when you when you start
unpacking that in yourself
we're all a curious mixture of
masculinity and
femininity you know we're all you know
all you know
qualities which are considered to be
masculine qualities which consider to be
feminine
you know we're all we're all a mixture
of those uh
so in terms of but we are making sure
those but i am binary like i've never
questioned my quote unquote gender
identity i've never felt like well maybe
i'm not
a man like it's just never occurred to
me
right so i'm i'm binary let's say france
is questionable
[Laughter]
but it's it's what it is what this means
it means you're talking about your
personality it's how you feel
comfortable with yourself
with your body uh with those things so
but this this is
this is separate from our sex you know
we're here we're
we're human beings we're mammals and
like any other species of mammals
there are two types of every species
there's male
and there's female and if if people
don't believe me i usually say we'll go
and speak to your biological parents i
bet you've got one of each
uh because that is sex sex is binary
uh then we talk about personality gender
how we feel about ourselves our identity
and that's different and what we've what
what's happened and where we've where
we've confused ourselves is
we put all this together in one so we're
talking about uh
we're talking about uh uh you know we're
talking about men
we talk about women and then we talk
about this non-binary
in the middle as if to say somebody who
is not a man and not a woman
ah but what i would come back there to
say is
there are people of both sexes who
who identify as non-binary but
what interests me is is the way that
and again this also i'm going to say is
is
possible political dynamite is what
female non-binary people
and male non-binary people uh you know
their experience in life is different
because as human beings you see somebody
who
isn't stereotypically presenting as man
or woman anything
but as human beings we look at the
people and we think oh yeah this is a
male person who is uh
who is presenting in a androgynous fana
manner
this is a female person who's behaving
in an androgynous manner
but as human beings we we view
we you know we we do take note of the
uh of the sexes and we do relate to each
each sex differently we all do
we've got we've got millions of years of
evolution which is which which has led
us here you know we are
we are we are our bodies in that way uh
so when you start talking about
non-binary is
if you separate the two if you put sex
to one side and say
you know we're all we're all male or
female that's a biological fact
so one two three we're all male people
uh
that i would say is you know is is
should be
uncontroversial then we look at
personality uh
separately call it gender call it
identity whatever you like
and then we've got uh you know people
who were
quite happy with all the uh quite happy
with the stereotypes which are put on
them
quite happy about going down the street
saying i'm a man it doesn't bother them
and
and there's others who struggle with
that some of us some of us transition
so that we're there you know presenting
as the opposite sex
uh and others sort of you know will
prefer to
be presenting as as neither but
when when you actually uh when you
actually said when you take that
personality
spectrum when you talk about non-binary
the moment you create
non-binary people in this spectrum well
the two p
the two ends are just is it fair to say
that is a binary
or are they just two ends of a
non-binary spectrum so
i think your question makes more sense
if you separate the two
and then say you can make a personality
what you like that's fine we can talk
about that
but when it comes to sex you know that
is i'm a science teacher
there are two sexes and we can't change
it so if we keep non-binary out of that
then it all makes more sense but that
again
is the political issue people like to
identify out of their sex
but uh we can no more you know we no
more identify out of our
height or our age you know i you know
you know it's these these are just facts
of our bodies you know
my body is male it's 182 tall and it
came into existence 52 years ago you
know i might not want that to be the
case
but that those effects of life and
debbie do you think this hyper focus on
gender
is helpful as to what we're doing now
how we seem to be pulling everything
apart and there seems to be
genders being created you know almost
every day
the fact that we talk about non-binary
is that actually helping us as a society
no no it isn't
uh i think people should just be allowed
to be themselves and we shouldn't need
we shouldn't need to invent a category
to identify
into to our la allow ourselves the
people we want to be
so you know if somebody wants to uh
you know if somebody's personality type
is to where
you know is to wear their hair in an
unusual fashion color it blue whatever
then just just do it you know don't feel
you've got to identify as a certain
category
in order to uh to be be yourself
uh you know and and that you're right
there are so many of these different
categories
and you think why do people need these
uh
you know when we talk about the lgbt
wxyz cure you know what what
you know all these different categories
that people create for themselves
create for society you know at year one
which i've come across which i i'm
you know i'm struggling to get my head
round but i keep getting myself into
trouble is
is people who identify as asexual well
you know and i've said well what's
what's the big deal you just
you just don't you know if you don't
need a a romantic sexual partner well
it's
it's an issue you don't need to worry
about just you know what what's the
issue here
why do you need a label to say you know
i just
don't you know i prefer being by myself
i don't i don't need uh
you know i don't i i'm not sexual i'm
asexual
but i got myself into an awful lot of
hot water
for uh for denying people's identity but
i don't see if that's the person they
want to be i don't see need to see
that why they need to create a category
that they then need to uh restrict them
into
this artifact completely artificially my
view category which they've created
i do think people should be themselves
have you ever been abroad and felt out
of place because you didn't speak the
language
no because i voted brexit brexit means
brexit i know that sometimes you're
abroad you don't speak the local
language it's very awkward like france
is talking to a woman
so you have to shout do you want to
learn another language
i don't for obvious reasons but if you
do
babble is quite simply one of the finest
language learning apps in the business
babel offers
a clear and easy to use interface they
have daily 10 to 15 minute lessons
that have been proven effective across
many studies
showing that you can learn up to 14
languages that they offer
so it doesn't matter if you struggle
with language maybe you find it
difficult to pick up
or maybe you're just english right now
babel is offering
our fans six months free on a six-month
subscription
with babel using our special code which
is of course
trigger that's babble b a b
b e l dot co dot
u k slash play and use the promo code
trigger look at that spelling he learned
english on babel
i did but seriously go to babel dot co
dot uk
forward slash play use our code trigger
and enjoy babel
it's a good point that you said that
people should be themselves but isn't it
also a way of
garnering attention for yourself
creating an identity
therefore that people notice you
therefore that you
you can explain yourself succinctly to
the world
in a way that you couldn't before it's
far more difficult
to explain who i am if we go into the
complexities
but if you just say you know cis
straight white male boom it's done
yeah it's it's a our people our people
choosing these identity levels to be
special
yeah uh because there are different
flags for all the you know the uh the
the all the different flags there's the
lgbt flag there's the uh
you know the trans flag whichever but
everybody knows that one
uh there's the there is an asexual flag
there's a bison you've got them all at
the back
yeah and there's a heterosexual flag
there is a heterosexual flag have a
guess what color is it
it is i don't know is it like all the
primary colors
no not red no no no black sheds of grey
is it shades
so uh so they picked the dulles color
they picked the absolutely dullest color
to actually say this is the heterosexual
flag
and what you said to people is why
be as boring as this when you can have
all these colors and all these separate
identities
yeah that's interesting and do you think
this politicization that we're seeing
with the lgbtqi plus but particularly
focusing
on trans people is this helpful is this
helping you in any way
it doesn't help me at all uh i i
transitioned i got got on with
got on with life the one most important
piece of legislation for me
was the equality act which gave us our
own
uh protected characteristic of gender
reassignment and what that means is
is that i can't be treated less
favorably
or you know because of i've gone through
gender reassignment
so i can't be sacked from my job people
use people used to be dismissed from
their jobs
and employers would say oh we support
what you're doing but
you'll be too much trouble so you know
here go uh but so i can't be denied
goods and services in shops i can't be
uh
you know uh so that that protects me now
to be honest this this is this this is a
great country you know
the vast majority of people are
open-minded
liberal accepting there are you know
there are there are people around as
we as we all know who are not but on the
whole it's a very accepting country and
has been
but what the what the equality act did
was uh
it gave people the confidence in which
to do that to say i'm doing the right
thing
and the law says i can do the right
thing and i transitioned and got on
and got on with the job uh my aim of
going to school each day was to teach
children not to be a
not to be a trans person there and and
that was working
then it was around 2014 2015
uh big campaigning organization started
jumping on this
to use this as a almost like a civil
rights movement
which in my view was never necessary we
were getting along just fine with trans
people
because we we keep being told and this
is an important part of the conversation
that we haven't had yet but
you bring it up we keep being told that
if
uh you know if trans kids if such a
thing exists if
children with gender dysphoria uh if the
if they're not given
the right emotional support if they're
not you know given help
with their transition if they're not
their pronouns aren't used if their
parents don't immediately start going
well you say you're a girl then you're
whatever it is if that doesn't happen
then uh
you know suicides are very high we're
told that the reason we need to
to be very aware of this and ver you
know raise awareness
is that trans people experience a lot of
hate and abuse and violence and
and you know and that worries me i don't
want to be contributing to people being
hurt
you know and if that you know and i
think the argument goes well you know if
i just use the right pronouns and if i
just you know
don't worry too much about the nuances
of it if i just accept why i'm being
told
well at least i'm not hurting people
that's how a lot of people think and
frankly probably until we started the
show that's how i thought i was like
well
i'll just do what's asked of me because
i don't want to hurt people who are
already vulnerable
you know is that not all true you've
asked a lot of questions that i have
uh a lot of questions i want to come
back to what you've said about children
that is an issue that
that is that's a huge issue but
coming back to this how trans people
live in society it's not my experience
at all that there's a lot of people out
to get me i live
you know my life is as normal as anybody
else's
and there aren't people hiding around
the corner abusing me it doesn't happen
uh this week in parliament uh jess
phillips read out karen ningala smith's
list of
the 100 more than 100 women who have
been murdered by male people including
partners
this year when we talk about trans
people the impression is that
the world is much more dangerous for
trans people but uh
there's there wasn't there wasn't a list
to read out from the uk
this year or last year we have a
international transgender day of
remembrance every year
uh where we're remembering people in uh
largely in different completely
different societies to ours
where where life is diff is is very
difficult for anybody who is different
for for women for trans people for gay
and lesbian people
they're very very different societies to
ours but enough about my country of
russia
the claim that this is somehow a
dangerous society for
trans people is well i i'd say from
first-hand experience
it's ludicrous and it's a political
claim that's been made
uh but then going on to what you were
saying about the children if we
don't affirm children's identities well
you know we need to ask the question we
go back you know why was this not picked
up
40 years ago 30 years ago whenever
when there wasn't a spirit of children
committing suicide because their
identities were not recognized it wasn't
happening now
my own situation was from three years
old i knew i had
uh i knew i knew i had some
psychological issues i desperately
wanted to be a girl
i knew i knew this these these wishes
were so shameful
i couldn't i couldn't tell anybody so it
was all it was all buried down
but i i would have
you know i would have benefited from
that uh from that being unpacked and
helped to say look you know
you just you know you you've got you
know you've got these
feelings uh they're not your fault
you've got these feelings
you can't be a girl because you're a boy
but let's have a look and see how we can
make
you know help you become comfortable
with yourself what
what's happening now uh and what i've
what you know what's happening now is
that children are being told
well you can you you really the other
sex you can be the other sex and
if that had been said to me in 1971
1972 1973 i'd have been i
i would have been clamoring to
transition
and be the other sex and where would
that have left me
you know uh you uh you you have
pre-pubescent children at primary school
well you know before puberty
children can grow either cut their hair
or grow their hair long
what you wear it's relatively easy to
pass as the other sex
but then puberty comes along and that is
the
that's the key to adult life and before
before children actually understand what
it means to be an adult now
we're saying to them you know you can
choose whether to go through that
puberty
and that puberty and they're and they're
they're of equal
they're of equal value you know it
doesn't matter this is values you can be
you can grow up to me i don't man i can
be an adult woman you choose
and if i'd been given that choice in
1975
you know 1980 attitude was chosen to be
a woman
beca our chosen big girl because that
that's what i wanted would you not
rather that it happened
no why not because i wouldn't have had
my children
and uh as human beings we uh
you know there's various things that
drive us we are biological and
you know within within within humanity
if there wasn't that driver to have our
own have our own children
our species would sort of die out very
quickly i think so that's there
and that's very strong in me and and as
i became an adult i really wanted my own
kids
and i've had my own kids and if
i transitioned as a child that would
never have happened
and that to me those those things are
far more
important than that and and then we're
saying
i really wouldn't have been a woman and
never have been a woman
uh i would have been a boy who had
transitioned before puberty and then
been given synthetic hormones so my body
would have developed how it had done
maybe
you know the the difference now in life
would have been that uh
rather than being you know my my voice
would be would be higher well
so what uh and uh
i wouldn't be quite as tall as i am but
i like being one meter 82 actually
you know so there are advantages i
wouldn't i wouldn't you know if
you know if transgender therapies could
uh chop 10 centimeters off your height
so i i i
i wouldn't go there because i like being
tall so
i just think for me if this had been
presented to me
i would have taken it and it would have
been the wrong thing and this is from
somebody who is transitioned
uh whereas other people other friends of
mine say
that uh when i was a child
i felt like this but i i grew out i grew
out of those feelings
and those are more often than not women
and the number of women i've spoken to
who as they approached puberty felt
really
negative about this because they
realized what he was going to do with
their body
they realized that they weren't you know
that roots in life were being shut off
uh so they were desperate to be the
other sex but then
then those that those feelings went away
and
uh what really concerns me about what
we're seeing with children
is that this generation now that i've
been that i've been told they come with
the other sex
the vast vast majority of them now are
girls you know it's
around you know two-thirds of the
referrals to gender clinics
and now girls and there is no
there's no big army of middle-aged women
coming out saying
oh now that society's changed i can
transition there's middle-aged women
saying
yeah when i was that age i felt like
that too but i grew out of it
and i really do worry about what we're
doing to these children
uh just tell them that they can be the
opposite sex when they can't
making those promises to them and then
when puberty comes along saying you know
there's this medication which
and uh and surgical treatments which can
make you into some sort of facsimile at
the office where they don't say that so
we
didn't make the opposite sex and it's
just not true
and the uh you know
the the impact on those children
in the future i really do worry about we
talked about women's rights before
you know this this trans has become has
become the hot topic of
debate uh it will pass on to something
else i'm sure something else will come
around
and if women's rights have been
compromised and they can be reclaimed
but if children's bodies have been
damaged they're damaged for life
and they only have one body and that is
something as adults we need a responsib
we need to take responsibility for that
and there are too many people who are
saying oh well you know if that's what
if that's what's going on now there's no
no you know no christian here but
there is there is a widespread attitude
that uh i don't know about this this
you know cleverer people than me uh come
and do this if it's not harming anybody
but children's bodies are being harmed
and i think as adults we all have a
responsibility to look
think critically at what's going on look
at both sides of the argument
and when claim when people make claims
as always ask that question you know
where is the evidence that they're
citing for this claim
because i think all too often we're
hearing
two you know the evidence which is cited
is is that uh
everybody thinks this which is an appeal
to popularity
or you know people in in authority think
this which is an appeal to authority
whereas those you know anybody who
thinks
who thinks about issues knows that those
are very poor that's those are poor
support to arguments
so kids worry me yeah and do you know
the thing that that
shows that there's something quite wrong
with society where
we're effectively well we're
transitioning these kids
and that's seen as the right thing to do
when we all know that children
are simply not capable psychologically
of making these huge life choices
yeah and very very young children as
well three four-year-old children
parents are taken to the gender clinics
are getting referrals from children
who are aged three four five uh it's
you know and then you've got to ask the
question why are parents doing this what
are parents seeing
in their children to actually to
actually do this
are they seeing gender non-conforming uh
behavior
this is the question this is where
parents need to be challenged why do you
think your child is trans
well my son or whatever language they
use
prefers to wear dresses well why can't
boys wear dresses
uh and do you the questions she's saying
of parents is
do you have a problem with your son
wearing dresses
because my worry is is that parents have
issues about children exhibiting not
exhibiting gender non-conforming
behavior and this is a way of helping
the parents
address their issues better to have a
you know if better to have a gender
conforming daughter
than a gender non-conforming son perhaps
now
that is uh that's a possibility of
what's going on and if that is what's
going on
then this four-year-old five-year-old
child who is being told by all the
adults around them that they are
really a girl is should be concerning
everybody
yeah and it's it seems that we don't
we've stopped
understanding what it means to be a
child a teenager
which is a continual process of
questioning your identity
you know we all had when we were going
through puberty
the reason it's so painful is because
you you don't know anything
everything has changed you don't know
who you are you don't know what you're
going to be
you don't know what your sexuality is
all these things they're all up in the
air
so to then come along and say to these
kids well you know you're trans just
seems to it's it just seems to me abuse
if i'm being honest
i would agree with you yeah it is and
rather than saying to children uh
you know you've got lots of questions
what we're saying is here is the answer
you're trans and all the issues which
children do struggle with
and as you grow up the you know
the the transition we you know we talk
about transition and and it's been it's
become a law deter transition is
something
is something a trans person does but we
all transition as we move through life
we're different people now
as to who were 10 years ago 20 years ago
and this is all the transition through
life
and there's lots of questions that we
have lots of issues that we grapple with
uh but and we and we're desperate for
answers to those uh
issues now the if the answers were
simple we wouldn't be
you know life is complicated human
beings are complicated
uh you know one of the things i teach
physics and someone say
physics physics is easy human beings are
difficult because human beings are
complex
so we've got all these issues which
we're grappling with
and then to come to children yeah we
know you we know you've got uh
anxiety issues we know you've got uh
issues with
uh you you know working out your
sexuality and what that means to you
we know you've got issues with gender uh
but as
people growing up it's things that we
have to work through those to ourselves
so we understand ourselves
and we come we become comfortable
ourselves but
what we're telling children is ah this
is because you're trans
and here is a pre-packed solution to
your problems
uh you know in the in a pink and blue
box
this is who you are and suddenly you've
got a a ready-made answer it's a
pre-pack answers
a ready-made community who uh you know
uh who uh to move into because the other
thing about growing up it's friendship
groups and
being excluded from friendship groups
and uh you know
bullying and uh you know as as a t
you know as adults we're forever you
know we're forever
d you ever having to uh help children
through those issues
uh such a child who doesn't quite fit in
because
all children don't quite fit in none of
us quite fit in anywhere
because we're different to everybody
else to say look
here is the pre-pack solution including
ready-made community ready-made role
models ready-made this ready-made that
ready-made the other
it's denying them the opportunity to
find themselves francis and that is that
is abuse
it it is and uh and the the last
question i want to ask on this debbie is
to me this isn't just a problem we see
with children
or with the trans issue it's right the
way through society
where what we desperately want is very
simple
easy solutions to deeply complex
problems would you agree with that
well yes that's that's the uh we we've
talked about binaries before
we do like we do like to uh you know we
do like to uh
reduce everything to a binary you know
brexit or remain
yeah you know or lockdown or uh you know
or whatever or letting it rip
yeah you know the idea of nuance to
think there are there are issues here
we've got to grapple with
and let's hear all let's hear all the
arguments and come up with
solutions which give the majority of
people the majority of what they want
which is what political debate is all
about
uh gets lost in this uh it strikes me
that
you have an insight into something that
we've not talked much about on the show
but it's interesting to me because
you've lived both as a man and as a as a
trans woman a transsexual woman
but you've lived in society where people
thought you were a man and then now
where people think you're a woman
and i wince a little bit you mentioned
male privilege and that's not because i
don't think
people are privileged in different ways
each i just wins because that word is so
misused now often
the word privilege so tell us
what what is different when you live as
a man and when you live as a woman what
have you noticed what it has it been
like what inside have you got because
none of us have that experience
right yeah it is it is interesting uh in
committee meetings for example
as a man i'd expect certain bits of body
if i wanted to make a point in a
committee meeting
you sit forwards like this you look
around you make eye contact with the
chair
and you get you get brought in
if i'm uh and other people naturally
will will bring will bring you into the
debate in the meeting
if i'm in a if i'm in a committee where
i've not been clocked
you know so i don't i i i don't i don't
you know if if it's a group of people
that's come together and sometimes in my
work
i do i will turn up on a committee with
to do something and i've just been sent
i've been
sent along uh representing another group
for example
uh i'll just announce myself as oh i'm
debbie hitton
i'm a teacher and i'm here representing
so-and-so
you know that's uh and i i'm not i've
not been clocked then i'll be treated as
a woman
and you can make the same you can make
the same eye contact with the chair
you can make the same body language and
you get ignored
uh it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't do
the same thing does it matter if they're
a man or a woman the committee chair
no so women will ignore you because
you're a woman women will give way to
men yeah
that's interesting and they won't give
away they won't give away to other women
so you don't get your voice in early
enough now
now you might say why does that matter
debbie you'll get your voice in
eventually because you put your hand up
and eventually you'll come to
come to you but you might be the fourth
person to speak in the debate once other
people have
made their minds up so i noticed that
but
and here's the interesting thing is if
i'm clocked as a trans woman
i get treated as a man in that debate
now and
actually actually it's it's almost like
super male privilege because nobody
wants to upset me you never upset the
trans do you know
well that's what i was going to say i'm
not sure that's about maleness i think
that's
more i'm just assuming but hear me out
is that
people are now so worried about
offending anyone who's in any way a
minority that they'll [ __ ] let you
speak forever yeah they do
and uh you're young the community meets
there and say i'm debbie hurt and i'm
i i'm i'm a trans i'm a trans woman and
i've had such a difficult
i've such a such a difficult time
through life i've been persecuted and
oppressed every opportunity
and i have struggled to get here four
people abused me on the trend this
morning
i was i the a person at the chief
station gave me a funny look
yeah and and i've got here and i feel so
distressed and uh
but i know i'm within friends here and
oh
you can talk forever yeah so that that's
like that's like super privilege
but even you know so i've i've known
what it's been like to be a man
and i've know i i know what it likes to
be treated as a woman
and yeah and when you come out as trans
you just it's so
this it's when i hear this about trans
people being uh
you know the most depressed i'm thinking
for crying out loud
you know you know and and do you think
maybe that's just
people talking about like their
childhood like growing up in the 70s
you know it was a different society yeah
i think if you'd come out in a meeting
then and said i'm actually trans and
i've been you know
someone looked at me funny i don't think
you would know that reaction they
wouldn't have done but
it's it's uh what the question you asked
was
is there a difference between is and i
would say male privilege exists in those
meetings where
political decisions are made yes
everybody will have the
have their way but consistently male
voices will get heard
first and before female voices and
it's incremental just a little bit here
a little bit there a little bit there
somewhere else
and it means that society tends to get
run
for the benefit of men rather than
benefit what about other stuff francis
let me just
follow up on this you know you talk
about uh
making yourself look like a man when
you're walking home at night or whatever
because it's safe actually i mean you're
more likely to be a victim of violence
if you're a man that
those that's a statistic not sexual
violence so that that's the thing
but um what what else do you notice
about
being a woman and and how people treat
you differently to
what to us versus when you you appeared
as a man
there isn't there isn't much uh when
because
in in uh situations where we're well
known with
family you tend to get treated as who
you are yeah you know and and
and for my close family to suddenly
start treating me differently because i
have now said i'm i'd prefer to be
called something else and i'd
it didn't happen i know and at work i
tend to get treated as
as me uh out in the street when people
treat you differently it's it's hard to
say you know
it's what what is what what's the big
thing about
how i want to be treated differently as
a man or a woman
and as i've tried to unpack this within
myself
it's not about you and it's not about
the rest of society it's it's
it's purely large and squarely about me
and how i relate to myself and my body
that that's that's the key to it and
society
is for me is a bit of a bystander and as
long as you'll allow me
to uh live my life without persecuting
me oppressing me and you do
then i don't i don't i don't have a
problem in
in you know in living here it's it's
it's a great place it's the uk for
trans people to live it really is and uh
you know
it really does upset me when uh people
say you know it's
it's really dreadful yeah everybody's
out to get us because
they're not and if we whip ourselves up
into some sort of frenzy about that then
then we will not be living we'll be uh
just living in fear of
nasty things happening to us and uh it's
probably not gonna happen
and we look at the fact that we have
these groups now
and it just seems that we're more
polarized more divided than ever
how do we get some form of healing how
do we actually
come together and try and bridge the gap
between all of us
in order that we can actually have a
better and more harmonious society
i think we need uh we need to take
identity
out of political debate we need to be
looking at
people's rights to do things rather than
people's rights to be things
so that whenever we start basing laws
and policies
around identity when people being things
then we have big huge problems and
identity politics is
it just it just leads to it just leads
to so many issues
and whenever politics gets divided on
identity
it becomes you know we when it with
problems that become insurmountable
like you know like in the north of
ireland for example where politics is
divided on identity it's just a constant
issue to try and uh
move you know move issues forward
whereas what we should be doing here we
should be
we should be moving the debate along
people's rights to be people should
have a right to uh you know be whoever
they like you know
we are good let's face good and said we
are individuals
but move the debate for the rights to do
things
uh so our rights too you know wear a
skirt for example
now wouldn't it be better if we pushed
for push for the
law not to say because i identify as
trans
i have a right to dress like this
without being abused
how about just saying everybody in
society has a right to dress like this
because they're human beings
you know so we take it away from the
identity and say you have a right to do
this you have a right to do this you
have a right to do this
and that i think that i think would be a
way forward
you're talking about really letting
people
do what they want as long as they're not
hurting other people well yeah it's
it's the uh the law the law should be uh
permitting certain actions and
prohibiting other actions
and it's it's it's out of political
debate we know where to put the barriers
down so
we've all we the law protects our rights
to do things and not and
and stops us doing other things uh and
but in this issue it's become
it's become mixed with identity so we're
then saying well
we then start talking about your right
to be trans you know or prohibiting you
from being trans and this is where
people actually say we say
you're denying my identity what is what
we should really be doing he's saying
let's have a look at the issues here
let's have a look make these rights
universal
you know the you know trans rights are
human rights yes they are
let's have a look we'll give everybody
the right to uh
to dre you know to to to uh pick up from
either dress code
you know organizations traditionally
have had
one dress code for men one dress code
for women why
let's just let everybody you know select
from
either dress code uh then there's other
issues such as uh
it used to it just sounds bananas it
used to be an issue
changing uh you know your title from mr
to mrs
were you allowed to do this well you
know my title was doctor so i never had
that
but uh you know why should why should
that be an issue so
when there's when there's rights like
that we should be saying you know
let's cement those rights in everybody
has the right to do that
but then there are rights which do
affect other groups and that's when
we're coming down to the the debate
has been there about women's boundaries
and
essentially what's been happening here
is we that
male people have been demanding the
right to uh
to access rights which have been granted
to the other sex
for reasons known only to ourselves
so when i say i now identify as a trans
woman
therefore i need to uh i need to come
into
those women's species you've got to let
me into those spaces
uh i don't need to say why i identify as
a trans woman because that's
uh then that i'm i want to uh justify my
existence or whatever
nelson nobody answers that but without
without giving reasons
and then ex then identity policy would
say because i identify as this therefore
i must have those rights which
i think that is that leads to all sorts
of problems
and i think we should be looking at in
each case
the right to do things so we met you
mentioned toilets before which has
become an incredibly
politicized issue because it's it's
there as a case in point you know we
need we need to solve that
so on that one well i was going to ask
you on that one because there's
probably an even better question to ask
you there i was going to wrap up but i
think this is important
you talk about male bodied people and
want
all of that stuff i guess the question
if you boil it right down is if you
commit a crime
and you are supposed to go to prison
that's where this idea well people call
me he or she doesn't really matter
that's when
you know that stops being the case you
have to make a binary decision
at least at the moment you either go to
a male prison or a female prison
now i i don't know about the prison
system but i don't imagine the prison
system is kind to people like you
if you would send to a male prison right
but equally we've had cases where
male-bodied people have gone to a female
prison and have committed
unspeakable acts that should never have
happened so how do you square that
circle
well the prison prison the prison state
is divided by sex
and i'm male i would i would go to a
male prison we
need though to be looking at the my
rights to be protected from that
and this is this this is where my
campaign would come in
this is a this is a tough ask this is
this is this
is where you're going to be wanting you
know
separate facilities i'm not going to
want to share and sell with with
somebody else
uh showering and changing facilities
uh i pass reasonably well you know if
people
you know if people don't notice but in
the showers i pass
i pass much better in the showers than i
do any anywhere else
uh so but that that's a tough ask of
society
that's to certain society look i've done
this and i am expecting you
as society to pay a bit extra here and
put special facilities on here and
separate accommodation perhaps uh all
these things
i'm not saying and i think this is wrong
it's saying to society
we should ask women to budge up and make
room in their in the female estate
because that's what
that that in my view is the uh putting
people in danger i mean it's horrific
what
happened yeah so women and and the
profile of
a female offenders in prison is totally
different to the profile of male
offenders
if you look at how many uh sex what
women end up in prison for
is very different to what men you know
men end up in prison for
violent crime and you know when women
often end up as more often you know it's
been the accomplices of crime
and and you look at the profiles of
women in prison and a lot of things as
you think you're a bigger vic
you know you are you are a victim here
and a victim of circumstance
when you look at sex offenders around
you know around an eighth of male
prisoners are sex offenders
uh and there's close on a hundred
thousand men in the male estate so
that's
twelve and a half thousand sex offenders
the female estate is much more about
four thousand
it's not like there's two half of stairs
it's like it's like this and like this
and then suddenly you're saying well
we're then going to put this group of
males in with the females
and then when you look at the profile of
the uh of the male
of the trans you know the transgender
offenders
it's not an eighth it's close on a half
a sex offenders
yeah and there you've got you've got a
big problem and
and just to gloss it over and say you
know well this is just how it will be
and saying that hopefully there aren't
too many problems
in women's prisons uh i will deal with
we'll deal with bad cases we'll deal
with problems in the girl hope there's
not going to be too many i think it's
totally unexcited
what they've been what society's been
saying to women is you've got to budge
up and make room
and i've got total sympathy women who
say enough
you know we're not doing this and
they're quite right i agree i mean
that is an issue where it's like this is
so obviously wrong and just
so i guess what you're saying is you
need to make special arrangements for
male-bodied people who
present as women to to be treated
differently and
and it caught this is the thing you said
and it cost me more so the government is
much the government may be happier
to take the cheapskate solution which is
just to move us in yeah but you can't
have
women being raped by the people because
we don't want to pay extra money you
just i mean it's it's a no-brainer to me
that one
dave it's been an absolute pleasure
having you on the show and you've you've
cleared some of these things up for us
uh i'm sure we'll have to continue to to
try and get
wrap our heads around it as a society
but thank you so much for coming on and
as always we have one more question for
you
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about but we really should be
the power of the tech giants in san
francisco and seattle
to control what we think and control
what we're allowed to say
well put we've been talking about it
quite a bit yeah
good point thank you very much and
debbie if people want to find you on
social media wherever else where's the
best place to do that
uh twitter's probably the best place if
you search my name it'll it
comes up we'll make sure we'll put it in
the description
uh thank you so much for coming on and
thank you for watching we will see you
very soon with another episode like this
one or a live stream all of them go out
at 7 pm
uk time take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below